my boo can really mean a lot of things
it's a bit of a vague term actually but
we'll take a look at a few examples and
I think that this might be a bit of a
problem for you is this okay all right
so this one is white to move yeah
Queen to e5 check okay and then what do
you think I would play as black there
I could play King h6 where else do you
think I might play in that position
what's up because if you if you people
if you play if I play King h6 if you
play Queen if I check in King a chicks
what is why do I have a pretty good move
there try to calculate in your head
I might have multiple good moves but I'm
looking at one in particular area hmm
pawn to h4 but then after work takes a
seven or queen will rather Queen takes
e7 not totally clear yet Queen up for
check looks really strong because now
you can't retreat to g7 because Queen
takes off seven right and if you go to
h5 well you can guess that's not very
good but HUD somebody want to finish
that off for me
if you play if let me go for the
variation again Queen if I check King h6
Queen up for King h5 so how would white
play their g4 check and then I must play
King age four and then there's mate and
one where is it made of one in that
position create sex yeah so alright so k
h6 is not right but no I mean well
everything loses here for black actually
so King h6l loses to clean up for Jack
but if Queen e5 check if black plays
King v8
what would white play then work to eh a
pretty simple right okay so that leaves
us with King Daffy
so after Queen e5 check King f8 which is
white by
well queen h8 I can you know the point
is I can take on you seven and it's not
clear no that's okay it's part of the
part of the answer
kinda
hmm excellent very good so exactly or if
Queen Diggs where queen h8 is made yeah
very good so I'll put down on the board
for you guys now so Queen a5 check King
f8 and now Queen f6 is great quiet mode
we also got this it's kind of a
variation of a quiet move we call it
does anybody know this is also custom
times called just a nice little word for
when the Queen is used to make a small
move which is very powerful and easily
overlooked we call it a creeping move
and for some reason it seems to always
refer to the Queen because you're used
to the Queen making like long-range
aggressive moves and so sometimes when
it moves just one square in that fashion
it's unusual and they call it creeping
so quick Queen to f6 and now you know
White's just winning because we're
threatening Queen f7 and if you take an
e7 we have Queen h8 maid now the
interesting thing about that is if this
was a check or a capture I feel like
everybody would seen it like really
quickly because it wasn't a check or a
capture it was harder to see so even
though you are supposed to look at
captures and checks first you guys are
already at the level I think some of you
are about 1800 or aiming to be about
1800 that you're already kind of past
that and now you need to go back and in
addition to looking at characters in
check look at some of these quiet modes
now actually this is not really a quiet
moving away I think it's kind of a
variation of a quiet move in my opinion
it's a creepy move but it's also
something else which i think is really
overlooked in chess I think from anyone
from people who are starting out to
really strong fires underestimate the
fact that along with captures and checks
the third thing you should look for in
every position is why there's a third
type of forcing move which should
basically should be right up there with
captures and checks in terms of that
hierarchy well attacking moves but more
specifically because sometimes it's hard
to look at every single attack Nimmo
right I mean you can but a threat a
threat but specifically a checkmate
threat anytime you can threaten
checkmate
you know you should pretty much always
look at it
again in that hierarchy of like
sacrificing Brooke Sacrament bishop
there um the checkmate threat should
always be included there because
sometimes you know a lot of nowhere like
in this in this instance it looks
ridiculous because you lose a rock but
it wins so that is one kind of more
simple example let's look at some more
this one we can look at now and
hopefully if you saw the answer to that
last one you'll forget it by the time I
get back to it again
alright so I'm here we got a I switched
it to Train emo which by the way you can
do if you ever want to play solitaire
chess I know we had a tech class out
there which is a great class to take but
if you ever want to use chest bass and
not know what the grandmasters play
which is a great method of study called
solitaire chess you can click on that
tab called training so until you click
the arrow you won't see any of the move
so it's very similar so those of us who
still use chess books to use me like an
index card to cover up the next move
here you can use a training mode so
anyway this is Black team who's actually
probably couple wins in this position
for black but try to find one of them
one of them includes a nice little quiet
creeping move yeah black to move you can
see that by actually you can see that by
one dot dot dot I don't know if you can
see that but just good to know mm-hmm
Knight to f4 and then what would your
idea be after pawn takes off for work
takes a four queen d8 check King h7
would be a bad move because I have why
what's my number one goal and you're
trying to checkmate me besides not
getting checkmated sorry I mean when
somebody's trying to checkmate you you
really want to trade Queens right so
after Knight f4 point f4 work out for
Queen d8 check King h7 white would have
the fantastic Queen trading move mm-hmm
Queen exactly so you actually night
afore you have something a bit better
than that
get a couple moves that are better than
that actually I think there's two three
clear wins here
Oh F 6 is a little short because you
know there's a pawn on H 6
yeah we're cat 5 the rover rook up and
over
we're cat 5 2 H 5 looks extremely strong
but there's one other move which plays
into that whole creeping idea which I
really like as well yeah not work out
for now I don't know I mean I'm my issue
also with moves like that is maybe I can
like worst-case scenario sacrifice and
the positions not completely over but I
think I might have something better
again if you play work out for pawn f4
you're just playing Knight f4
threatening Queen G to mate yeah like
worst case scenario I'll play Queen
takes off for and it's it's I'm probably
losing but I think the move in the game
is a bit doesn't even allow that much
and the same with work at five
look for removes that thread and check
may okay so ninety-three and now if they
play pawn takes you three what happens
well Queen f1 King h2
not entirely clear so again you can make
use of a creepy move here which is also
kind of a similar to when you're
learning how to checkmate with two works
its instead of immediately checking
sometimes you fence your opponent's king
in Queen e2 yes that's just another
example that creeping theme which I like
okay get that before I actually do not
want to do this one yet okay this is a
nice one this is white to move and win
the quickest made because there's
actually a couple ways one but what's
the what's the quickest way to win work
out seven check I can keep your work on
you five you kind of let me out of the
cage a little bit bit caged in here is
it is black right you can't really move
anywhere but if I K if it seems like
anywhere I check you you lose control of
some important square all right yeah
it's very good ki h2 really nice quiet
move and now if work takes you seven
Bishop t3 is checkmate right oh yeah yay
well we want to what was the hint that I
gave you
oh that every yet every every time you
you check yeah you lose some key square
okay I'll give you fewer hence next well
some of the other ones are harder and
now I wanted to show you also this um
this really nice game between gotta camp
scheme Yasser Sarah Juan from this
year's US Championship which was also
voted as the best game of the tournament
by none other than anybody was following
the tournament and noticed who what's
that
yes Kasparov voted this is the best game
of the tournament which was an
interesting decision because some people
some people didn't agree with that
because this was all preparation that
Kamsky made for a match against Apollo
for the candidates but from Castro's
point of view and I totally agree with
him that just because this had been
prepared over the board didn't actually
affect the beauty of the moves so it's
kind of like it might have been homework
that Kamsky did and that was the
beautiful part but it's still a chess
game that we get to see so some people
will disagree and think that it's like
just kind of a different thing come up
with homework and that a game which is
kind of inspired over the board should
be given privilege over that for best
game Wars but I don't know I kind of
agreed with Kasparov what do you guys
think do you think that home preparation
should be eligible for winning Best Game
Awards how many people think that it
shouldn't
given any demerits for that you're you
don't understand the point our best game
well the point well the point of the
best game award is that sometimes you
can't win the tournament anymore
especially especially in the way that a
lot of American tournaments are run you
if you lose we don't have
single-elimination knockout right you
know have a knockout tournament so a lot
of times you're playing in the
tournament and you can't win so besson
game is nice and scented for people who
can't win the event anymore that's one
thing but don't even let the most
important thing the most important thing
is maybe that in chess is you're doing
two things right like you're trying to
win a tournament and you're also trying
to play beautiful games that will be
remembered forever and most people
actually have both goals because it's
hard to become a good chess player
without caring about making beautiful
games right like if you didn't care at
all about chess being beautiful you
probably wouldn't become a grandmaster
in the first place because it would be
rather boring right so anyway let's take
a look at this game I don't want to
really look at the whole opening so I'm
going to kind of go for the opening
pretty quickly
it's a CARICOM and like I said it's all
it's all basically theory at some point
they are they left the theory I'll show
you when that happened of course in
Grandmaster games especially
grandmasters of this caliber usually the
theory is goes on for quite awhile
unless somebody play something weird but
this is not weird this is basically the
main main main line of the Carol con
Carol con known for being a very solid
opening for black you know you see black
has this solid pawn formation which is
hard to break through and his King is
behind it so it's like not that easy to
attack him
meanwhile White's position is a lot more
active and in return for being so solid
usually when you're playing black you
can be solid but what you lose is your
positions a bit passive right so that's
often what happens you can play the
Sicilian which is much more aggressive
but then usually you have an easier time
white attacking you
so pluses and minuses but yeah sir Sarah
Wan is just a great player in these
types of positional lines and
so this is kind of perfect for him and
as you see white gets in a tacking
position anyway because you casso's
queenside usually when you castle on
opposite sides of the board it signals
that there's going to be a lot of
attacking going on for natural reasons
why do you think that might be why if
people castle on opposite sides why do
you think that means attacking is more
prevalent or more typical or happens
more how do you think you would try to
attack this King if you were light
exactly so when you're white here you
can push your king side pawns
particularly the Jeep on whereas if you
were castled you really wouldn't want to
do that because it would weaken your
castle position whereas now your Castle
queenside so you're not worried about
pushing these pawns forward and
especially in this position if you were
Castle kingside
you only have two minor pieces left on
the board so if you can't attack with
your pawns and let your works into the
game it's going to be hard to form
anything much right so this is really a
key idea here for white to try to get an
advantage and white played King to be
one why do you think you might have done
King to be one does that seems they go
random move right they also call this
the Grandmaster move off then King be
one King be one specifically is often
called the ground has to move why King
be one partly yeah
on the su 186 diagonal yeah exactly
king b1 just kind of multi-purpose move
which really finishes the castling
maneuver because normally when you
Castle kingside your Kings already on
the ideal square I mean sometimes you
move to h8 for specific reasons but g8
is a good square because it's defended
by all the pawns and it defends the h7
pawn where is the King on c1 is still
too centralized so it's almost like by
castling queenside you take that extra
move to really complete the move so you
see that almost all the time so see if I
gain some counter play and now we have
g4 which was mentioned already as kind
of the key way for white to expand an
attack in this position and we are still
basically in theory yep yessir took that
pawn on g4 and can be played Queen e2
which you know that it's kind of eyeing
this Knight on g4 and also the rook is
now lined up against this Queen and now
black played King to h8 which was
actually a novelty but data had already
analyzed this position over the board so
sometimes even if black has made a
movement has never been played before
white has already analysed it which is
indicative of how much works these
grandmasters do at home right they don't
just study moves that have happened they
said he moves that haven't happened and
how to respond to them and it becomes a
really big web in fact I think somebody
looked at this game and said that or
oftentimes you had people look at games
that were played on this you know
Grandmaster especially very strong
Grandmaster level and they're
disappointed because they were like wow
I had that novelty too and now I can't
play it in the case of King h8 I don't
think people were too disappointed
though because it didn't turn out so
well so now white just played worked H
to g1 attacking the knight and Knight
retreated Essex white took on c5 after
Queen to c7 now some of the fun begins
white starts with Knight to e5 just
posting up that not
and you know creating some potential
threats on f7 kind of making way for the
Queen and certain variations likely
Bishop takes e5 and now what do you
think
wait did
now think a little bit longer it is not
not particularly simple it's kind of a
longer calculation here try to calculate
as far as you can
before kind of weakens the this king so
you don't really want to move upon their
attacks the bishop momentarily but then
we can't move pawns backwards so our
King would be one will be forever weak
right that's why we don't like to move
the pawns in front of our King now if we
could go there and then go back to be to
later be a lot different
so we're key seven to something to be
analyzed and you should also be
analyzing other things right what else
would you be analyzing in this position
which is about four is probably worthy
of analysis uh-huh
work g6 is probably worth analyzing too
although it seems like I could take the
rook and then if Knight d6 can eat seven
Knight f8 wreck f8 you're not even
getting enough material you know so the
problem is sacrificing yeah you're just
you're sacrificing or working tonight
and you're only getting a rook back
right so you should all look at these
things but some of them you can dismiss
quicker than others
no those
so I mean we're g2 looks like a normal
move sure uh-huh
what else worked you two with the idea
of just playing working one also and
that would certainly be an idea that
would be considered bishop seat so you
guys are mentioning some normal moves
but what else should be in your list a
Ken Betts hmm
so Bishop takes if you play Bishop takes
h6 and your opponent plays ghx how might
you try to continue what would be like
the most obvious trying and like well
queen g4 then I can take but if you were
trying to if you were trying to like
thread in a checkmate or a Czech Queen
f3 threading the knight on f6 but ii v
hanging yeah so Bishop h6 you played
with your basic switch it did happen by
the way and your opponent plays g h6 now
try to figure out what to do
Queen where Queen d2 is a good tribe
because you're threatening Queen takes a
six and then Queen g7 mate very good
well well okay yes well look at that -
but if Queen d2 what do you think on
black would reply well that's one
possibility
what else just because I think you know
I there's an even better move there for
for black if Queen d2 I can also do what
caption the night because after Queen h6
night h7 the queen guards the g7 square
so probably 98 it's possible as well so
you were you're testing another move
okay and then if Knight takes T seven
queen g4 threatening Queen g7 mate and
then if I play rook to g8
at what point its notes White's move now
so he's analyzing work T 797 and then
you wanted to play queen g4 in that
moment thready in Queen g7 mate and then
I said also I could also play Queen
takes e5 there as well that seems much
better than work ta yeah sorry so we're
these 797 queen g4 Queen takes e5 yeah
so work three 797 what did you suggest
something else anybody have another
suggestion remember always look at
checkmate threats
okay so now Queen d2 because unlike
Queen g4 when you play Queen d2 Queen
takes T Phi it doesn't really help much
because Queen age six is still mating
right but what can wait what can black
do at that point so worth e 797 Queen d2
so already this is kind of a quiet move
but kind of not
it's a quiet move because it's not a
capture or a check it's easy to overlook
but in a way it's not apply it move
because it also threatens checkmate and
like I said quiet moves that threatening
checkmate should always be in that very
top hierarchy button just like Queen g4
by the way Queen g4 is also in the top
hierarchy because it threatens checkmate
on one but after Queen d2 what's the
only way for black to stop checkmate
except for Bishop e3 but you know Bishop
e3 is just what's the only the other way
so Rafi 797 Queen d2 King hmm yeah
gotcha and now what do you do is why
this was all preparation
so we're looking at again rookie 797
Queen d2 King h7 so yeah looking after I
think it looks like you're smiling you
had an idea
but I stole the I can still gravity I
can still grab b5 at the end because
it's protected by the night as well so
try to visualize that position and come
up with the answer it's not easy but the
fact that it's a quiet move might be
able to help you out actually I'll give
you a further hint they call this the
hardest the easiest move to overlook in
chess the easiest type of move to
overlook in chess especially in
blindfold chess which you're kind of
doing right now because well not really
but you're visually you're using a board
to visualize but it's not like a real
chess board but the better you get at
this the easier it will be to see it in
the three-dimensional one
you move Queen d2 Queen d2 is ready made
on age sex and then King h7 so the
position is work t7 Knight takes d7
Queen d2 King eight seven and now it's
white to move wait to move in the wind
sure rook d7 Knight takes d7 Queen d2
hitting HX King eight seven well I can
take yeah and then I can move my knight
yeah but maybe I can move my knight too
I could maybe move my knight to f6 and
then after takes on h6 I have like I
have a lot of things well we'll go would
tell me where what you're trying to do
exactly so work d7 97 Queen d2 King h7
no that's not quite right
what that's right you got it that's
exactly right good job yeah so that in
the reason they call it the hardest move
to find in chess we find that well first
of all Queen d2 is kind of a quiet move
right but then that this is a real
beautiful move 94 I mean just
outstanding because the combination
began with such brilliant tactical
flashy things like Bishop h6 and work d7
but really the most pretty move of all
was this Knight G form of and they call
that the hardest move to find in chess
especially blindfold
it's a knight retreating move for some
reason moves that retreat the night
seemed to be difficult for humans to
find especially when you're trying to
like look far in advance or play
blindfold so 94 and now it's impossible
to defend h6
and everything is going to crumble once
you take on a check
and what there were coming in very
beautiful game I mean the only thing you
can the only you can't just that you
can't stop Queen thx yes question you
could play King g7 and then I'll play
Queen takes h6 check and then after you
play King GA
how can i checkmate now mmm night where
what do you wanna play the night
anywhere but there's one move that's
better than all of them well not really
not really there's two moves that are
made of one two moves made of one
everything else doesn't made in one
right yeah so two moves made in one
which move you want to play yeah that's
a good one that'll work he that's double
jack so he doesn't have time to play
Queen g3 right
the other main one is Knightly five
because he can't block with a queen yeah
that's a good question I mean it was it
was kind of far back so I don't think he
anticipated all these like sacrifices
well obviously not otherwise he wanted
to played it I mean honestly work to you
sevens kind of difficult to say because
that's a sacrifice but you're saying
like all the way back I mean he played
it really long ago you know and if you
had played it for you play King H I'm in
here actually just wouldn't have worked
because why it would have been able to
play what here yeah Queenie for check
and then FF i we pick up a pawn and I
guess you could take care but that looks
unlikely to work out very well for you
so
good question out I think it's a really
great game because it has everything
it's got the it's got the crazy
sacrifices and then it finishes with a
quiet mo so I like that you get a little
bit of both but that being said it was
all preparation so it's kind of a matter
of taste whether you think that is a
legit best game contender but I just
love that game and oh by the way just
FYI after work day seven Yaser took with
a queen because you saw the 97 was
losing by four so instead he went for
this position where he's got the work in
the two pieces but the problem is Queen
d2 is still in the position for King
this and this so yeah still didn't end
very well all right let's take a look at
a couple more examples of really nice
playin moves now that we saw that
inspiring example from a real game which
actually featured two quiet moves in a
row quiet I'm going to call it quiet a
score quasi quiet quasi quiet that
sounds good because it's not a capture
or a check so it's easy to overlook but
it's a checkmate threat so it's not
really that quiet okay this is a really
really famous position it's one of the
coolest positions ever yes some of you
might recognize this but so just give
everybody a minute
I guess nobody does recognize it okay
that's cool you're in for a treat
because we're not analyzing the whole
position today but I'll tell you I'll
tell you the names of the players and
later you can go home and look at the
full game it's a fantastic game white to
move and win I'll give everybody at
least a minute
that's a really good idea but if you
play nike5 there's just a little problem
actually it's a big problem on Iying oh
what's the big problem
exactly good so that's the only thing
blacks got going for him in the position
really that he's got this battery which
clamps down this night because otherwise
would just be completely over it right
and IG if I would just be overwhelming
because it would be the one piece that
breaks the camel's back right I mean
there's just impossible to continue
defending f7 with such so much
domination but luckily for black he's
got at least that covered
oops
Oh No Oh No how do I reach all these
pretty arrows it's getting worse
trying to make it better but it's
getting worse
okay I'm just gonna move what cold for
what mm that's a guy I'm sure I didn't
delete the game hope not Oh No
where is it okay there it is all right
our less
so I kind of give you some veiled hints
in that last response by the way piece
that broke the camel's back that was a
little bit of a veil of a linear now
it's unveiled as a hand
you won't get forward
not work out for I don't your your work
is hanging on d7 you don't see what your
yeah it doesn't really work like I feel
I'm jealous of you guys because you've
never seen this position before so when
you see the answer you're going to be so
happy whereas I've already seen it so
it's like old hat to me oh you let me
see what do you think not worked you for
I mean that's a good idea but I think
one there's a couple things there I mean
I've just got so many options to try to
defend I could play I could try to
defend with Queen takes a rock and then
if work three six pawn g6 queen g6 Queen
g7 just seems like to wish fall yeah
where you can say with you four also
yeah that's not it it either and it
sounds like you might have the answer
it's it's not well but if you play g4
you're thinking g4 well it's not that is
too aggressive it's just that it doesn't
work we're guys I'm in work at seven
Queen g6 work g7 yeah but no it's
definitely worth looking at I would look
at work f7 for at least a second or two
anyone got a got on the back of my Diaz
it's unusual that we have such complete
control over the position so no because
that would lead to me I can you keep you
keep fooling me I keep being sure that
you have the answer because the way that
you're about you phrase the question
you're so close
you're so close you've seen this before
bed okay no it's a really great well let
me be a little bit more specific about
my hand and I won't try to mix quite as
many metaphors I'll be a little bit more
straightforward so in chess you know
when you have an attack and it looks
like your attacks kind of maximized the
Queen's on a great square or the works
on a great square this work is defending
this rook which is pretty good this
Knight is actually doing a lot because
it's basically holding back two pieces
and two powerful pieces of that so
basically all these pieces are annoying
what they should be doing it it's a bit
of a generalization but that combined
with the fact that you look at some
stuff and none of it works means that in
order to win this game you really need
to get one more piece into the game you
know that net that would abuse you
should investigate that yeah
yeah that's exactly what happened in the
game Oh oops
yeah it's really awesome and there's
there's no way for black to really
defend against it because if you move
this King at 8/7 at any point you've got
FSM in it it's pretty it's a pretty
crazy and awesome finish and this was by
the way if you want to look at the whole
game or just copy it to your computers
because it's so cool it's a short time
on short time on I think it was about 91
but if you look up short time on there's
only there's only going to be like six
games so this one will probably come up
first
um I think can't remember Oh
obviously black had a very passive
position as you can see but it's been a
while since I I don't remember exactly
what the opening was I guess but yeah I
mean I don't know it sure play some
theoretical stuff maybe come on not not
as much but I'm really studying his
games and that much depth this is
probably the one that I seen more often
than any and then I sometimes read his
his columns and his endgame studies so
great game anyway this one is a little
bit more simple and it comes up a lot
though this is more about closing the
door yeah excellent very good working
you on excellent it's just it's just
basically a nice quiet move a lot of
times people would look at moves like
Queen h8 first but why not play a
working one first and then Queen h8 is
just on top of all good
this is actually from one of my own
games this one's wait to move out
know it so actually I started it started
let me give you the start so it started
with Bishop h7 check and then after
kinga f8 exactly queen h5 so again that
kind of quiet quasi quiet move in which
it doesn't come into the capture or
check category but it does come into the
threatening mate category which is very
important
oh is pinned sorry I should have
mentioned that well because it was so
fast yeah I went by I'm going pretty
fast now because you guys seem to be so
smart but let me show you one more time
and you know the move order is really
important in chess so a lot of people
would probably look at where castex
first and then on f6 Queen h5 and of
course there's a couple issues here
kcon g5 and also even if you didn't have
that like something like Queen c7 with
Drennen would stop with may threat so
that's a thing that in calculation is
extremely important move order a lot of
times you've got a great idea and if you
tweak the move order your great idea can
work in one line and not in the other oh
this one's pretty cool and that does not
give anything away because ninety five
is not the correct move I don't have any
idea why that's there but way to move
okay quickly quick
well the problem is I understand you're
trying to play Ricky 7mate but what's
the issue there Queen eight seven nine
eight seven work e7 is not mate because
we had a queen on h4 guard Z's on
okay it was first thing I looked at too
but I think the problem there is that
you don't have a not quite sure I think
I have a couple responses I guess your
ideas if ninety-eight Queen h7 or
something but I can also play work takes
h6 and I don't see a mate work see a
check here and then after King day c8
you mean Queen f8 and then hmm
King c7 yeah Queen III Thrones check
maid not not in one Queen f4 it's wait
wait Queen why oh okay I thought you
were kissing and the other line yeah
ankle height hmm we're G it was
suggested okay and then after and then
after work eight six it's not quite me
because you know Ricki seven check I
have 97 right and if you go if you play
Roxy a check I have King d7 so like
feels close to me but it's not really
made yeah sometimes the cool is quiet
moves are ones that are also really good
seem really positionally a week as well
kind of like King King g3 and last move
it seemed really positionally week
because normally don't want to develop
your King right and there's another very
common Prince so opening prince of all
one of the first things we teach
students
the dog develop your king aka tasseling
hmm queen III was suggested with the
idea of Queen e5 check getting on that
diagonal with Queen f4 seems like a good
response probably some other ideas too
might be able to block also with a
knight on e4 I just have a lot of
options so what's one of the other what
are some of the other things that they
teach beginners Castle early don't get
your queen out early like things like
that
anything else can they go control the
center I don't think this abuse hens are
actually helping there from I just look
for the right move
hi knight on the room is dim though
right and now about the rook takes Queen
rook check you mean were q7 check you
mean and then I play a 97
you night so if night eight were wicked
chicks
maybe what's that I said work takes
Queen right yeah and then after after
Knight b6 or any what I'm sorry I'm
looking I'm you guys are mentioning so
many different variations so like we're
looking at night a for and then after
work takes to h6 Knight b6 was mentioned
and now what's a threat work see a check
right and the only way for black to stop
it is something like Queen age 3 and
then you can play
mm-hmm yeah rookie 7 check and then if
Queen d7 or something where this t8 is
made anyway exactly so it's kind of
another cool one and I want to get
showing one more let's see I think I
should almost showed at the very
beginning okay here we go wait to move
in line
it's kind of a variation on creeping I
would say Valentine's Day special
romantics out there who are bringing
their their girlfriends the chess club
tomorrow night don't worry we will have
some chocolate so you won't look like a
total but it'll make a great story right
like think about what a great story
she'll be able to tell her girl friends
forever
my boyfriend open him to the chest come
on Valentine's Day what's up so if work
age 3 I and I take C seven and forked
eight work to age three night take C
seven Bishop g6 King g8 so so sometimes
the move order is really key okay so if
you were to play Bishop d6 first and
then I played night AC seven what's the
difference so if I play burgage three
check it's basically the same but
instead what can it what can what you do
exactly right that's a really cool one
it is very simple and it's also similar
to creeping because bishops tend to be
long range pieces so the fact that it
moved one one square and then one square
is kind of unusual and now now this is
just mating ah we're here oh you mean
just to go here yeah should be the same
I wonder if there's some difference
because the bishop is actually in take
now if I play doesn't really matter
because anything I do yeah but if I but
if I try to do that it doesn't really
help right because night eight six what
can you do here
yeah just rotate your takes a chicks is
just me yeah one second thought what
about um no yeah yeah it's all the same
yeah huh anyway yeah hello this looks
cool too I don't know they both look
cool and this is cool too so anyway yeah
any questions but yeah yes solving chess
problems can help you find quiet moves
and violent moves and games definitely I
mean the more you the more repetition
you do the more it will help also
sometimes if you don't get a problem
right you might want to notate that and
then come back to it and see if you can
get it the next time
you